one steward tries to hold one of the
external fences in place but there are
too many people pushing through he and
his two other colleagues are quickly
overwhelmed
[Music]
what are you doing
i've been asking
we counted at least 50 fans breaking
through running towards the club wembley
entrance
this video filmed from another angle
filmed at 5 37 p.m shows that area with
dozens of people making it into the
stadium grounds
they run up these stairs to level one
where the main access points directly
into the stadium are
less than 100 meters away on the north
east side of the stadium
oh no
a group knocks down a barrier
two mounted police officers move in to
stop others from
entering underneath
but there are easier routes for others
at 6 11 pm at least 10 people climb onto
a temporary toilet block on the south
side
by now large numbers of ticklish fans
are inside the grounds along with others
who have paid to be there and some are
about to breach the inner ring which
leads directly to the seating area
overlooking the pitch
a large crowd attempts to enter at
entrance point g
in the first 15 seconds of this clip we
counted at least 50 people entering the
stadium
at 7 20 p.m a group attempts to rush a
disabled entrance on the southeast side
of the ground
a number are successful as they
overwhelm the four stewards trying to
hold them back
we found two videos of this moment
some other fans already inside attempt
to block and fight those streaming in
the stewards are overrun multiple times
by the huge numbers trying to get inside